Disney
has just fulfilled
one of the the long long-standing dreams
of radical liberals with nothing better
to do than to make up problems Disney
well listen I'll let some random adult
on Twitter
uh explain the significance
this is not a drill all Quote The all
caps Disney Plus finally made a short
with a plus size lead
it's called reflect and it's part of the
short circuit short series let's just
say I was sobbing
at first I thought that this was
parody
I don't think it is
I think
what's the story here the story is that
Disney releases short films sometimes
which very few people see
and in this case they made a short film
about a fat girl
and
this does not seem like international
news to me but it was trending on social
media there's been a lot of commentary
about it this is supposed to be very
very significant and apparently it's
very very significant
to this woman not a drill finally they
finally made a short film about a fat
girl I didn't know this was something we
were all longing for that anyone really
was longing for but it had finally
finally and this one was brought to
tears over the sobbing then another
adult woman
took to Twitter said
uh 16 year old me needed this Disney
short before I quit ballet because I
didn't want to be the fat girl in class
anymore I'm glad the little ones will
have this 10 out of 10 for reflect it's
so wonderful and so
I look at these two accounts there were
a lot of others these were just the ones
that were lumped in with the trending
the completely viral all over Twitter
adult number one
pronouns in bio
checks out
number two
pronouns in BIO self-identified dog mom
and a teacher so that's good this is who
you want educating your kids right you
always want the pronouns in BIO
educating your kids right no I don't
think so
uh I don't have much of an opinion about
Disney making a short film about a fat
girl I
okay that's fine I don't watch short
Disney films I don't I don't watch a new
long Disney films I don't
that's okay I
though I I have opinions about a great
many things this is not something that I
have particularly strong feelings about
however
I do have strong feelings
about childless adults
who are completely obsessed with Disney
and more broadly I have strong opinions
about childless adults
who are obsessed with children's things
that's weird you shouldn't do that
I I have friends of mine
who
as adults
childless adults sometimes even just
alone will go to Disney World
or will they just can't wait for the
next children's movie to come out and
they're going to go see the next
children's movie on the the first day of
the movie or they buy toys they buy
children's toys for themselves just to
have the toys and so they get to play
with the toys and that it's it's not
just a few weird people that I'm making
fun of this is a social phenomenon that
seems to be growing in particular among
my generation the Millennials and it's
really weird and it's obviously related
to
the the fact that our generation is not
having children
and they're not getting married and
they're delaying everything and they're
not having as many kids and they're not
having kids at all in many cases
and these are obviously related
because there is there actually is
something natural about wanting to
experience childhood things as an adult
that's called Nostalgia that that's
totally normal
and there's a way to do it the way to do
it is to have kids and then you get to
experience it with your kids you get to
take your kid to the Disney movie and
that's not something that I'm exactly
eager to do but maybe I'll get a kick
out of part of the movie or you know you
buy your kid toys and then you play with
the toys with the kid and that actually
can be kind of fun
that's good that that's that's the right
way to channel your Nostalgia for
childhood and to keep your imagination
alive and all these things the the bad
way is to pretend to be a child the bad
way is to never grow up because when
you're a child You Do child childish
things and when you
the childlike things you know you do the
things that children do
when you grow up you're supposed to when
you become a man you're supposed to put
away the things
of a child
there's actually Kenny Loggins song
about this the Pooh Corner song You Know
help me if you can I've got to get back
you know it's actually a pretty good
song and it's a song he wrote in high
school I've mentioned it once or twice
on the show about how he wandered out
into the Hundred Acre Wood when he's
looking for you know his friends Winnie
the Pooh and everything but he can't
find them he's wandered a little bit too
far today and he can't get back he can't
get back to Childhood because he's
graduating high school now he's becoming
a man and it leaves you with a little
bit of longing but it kind of
some hope for the future and say okay
I'm going to do bigger things now I'm
going to do more adult things now but
and then he when he had children Kenny
Loggins he added a verse to the song he
said I actually did get to go back to
the Hundred Acre Wood because now my
little kid has my little Winnie the
Winnie the Pooh Bear and he's hugging
him and I get to see the world again now
through his eyes wow what a wonderful
thing
but don't for goodness sakes people
don't be overgrown children
whatever who who cares about the fat
girl in the Disney movie or the for
short film or whatever
that doesn't matter
what matters is
you getting really really excited to go
see a kids movie that you shouldn't be
doing that you need if you are getting
really really excited for the kids stuff
you need to grow your interests
and you need to look to hire things
because you're an adult and you got to
act like a man usually I do the Don
Corleone impression when it's some guy
whining about how he can't get a girl or
something like that or he can't but you
it you got to act like a man not just
from the sex perspective but from the
age perspective you gotta act like a man
act like a grown-up what's the matter
with you
now we get to
the much more philosophically
satisfying part of the show
and oh I'm sorry physically satisfying
part of the show that is when I kill
Jake crane that's right he lost the
fantasy football game I won it now he
has to eat a poison chip while I watch
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
oh